the familiar moment
marking the start of christmas only
illuminated the surreal scenes
of an empty new york
and there was little to cheer about on
the country's deadliest day
in the pandemic so far
america is breaking coronavirus records
and still bracing for the holiday surge
authorities fearing festive celebrations
will become super spreader events i
think the more people gather the more
they travel it'll it'll get worse
but i wanted to come see the tree anyway
it's been going on for so long
a lot of us are extremely tired and so
we just
took the chance and came out here anyway
to me it can't get any worse
you know in a bid to deter
crowds police closed the area
restrictions just one legacy of new
york's hellish first wave
and small gatherings are being blamed
for its second
police are doing everything they can to
stop people congregating here for the
christmas lights
the city the country is braced for a
surge in cases following the
thanksgiving holiday
and america already has more than a
hundred thousand patients in hospital
with covid19
that's nearly twice the amount it had at
the worst
point in the first wave
unlike the spring when new york was
america's epicenter
cases are now exploding across the
country
state after state reaching near hospital
capacity
los angeles mayor telling residents to
cancel everything
despite warnings against travel test
sites are
overwhelmed with new yorkers returning
from thanksgiving
the city's positivity rate now around
five percent
my brother has it right now my nephews
both have it my
i mean it's it's scary i just want it to
be over with so i can
go out with my friends and have fun
again it's just
work sleep eat that's it
a return to normal still feels a long
way off here
new york still empty of the usual crowds
the city even close to most other states
and the numbers paint a sobering picture
of what's to come
new infections at a record high across
the us
so the cases are going to go up again um
we're going to see that because there
obviously is a lag time from people
becoming infected to
having infections and then a couple of
weeks later
we'll two to three weeks later we'll
probably see an increase in the number
of deaths
so for many people it's going to be a
devastating christmas
the holiday season is only adding to
concern
a surge is expected across america
sally lockwood sky news new york